[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
après la parution de l'hebdomadaire
valeurs actuelles un rassemblement de
soutien à la députée de la france un
soumises aujourd'hui à paris à l'appel
de plusieurs associations
danièle obono avait été représentée en
esclave dans une fiction de
l'hebdomadaire la députée parisienne a
porté plainte
et rassemblement devant le siège des
grands médias français aujourd'hui à
l'initiative du collectif des gilets
jaunes ils demandent un meilleur
traitement d'informations selon eux la
censure de certaines personnalités
d'opinion pour servir les intérêts de
certains groupes politiques ou
financiers n'est pas admissible en
démocratie
un cortège rejoint par d'autres à paris
par les soutiens du fondateur de
wikileaks
puisque le procès de julian assange va
reprendre après demain à londres
lancement des concertations nationales
pour la transition au mali des
discussions entre les militaires au
pouvoir les partis politiques et la
société civile
le visant à ramener ses
la tête du pays une étape importante
alors que le pays est toujours en proie
aux attaques terroriste des islamistes
hier au moins dix soldats ont été tués
dans une embuscade près de la frontière
mauritanienne
[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue sur rt france à la une
de l'actualité ce samedi ce
rassemblement de soutien organisé place
du trocadéro à paris aujourd'hui pour
soutenir danièle obono un dessin
représentant la députée de la france
insoumise en esclave dans une fiction de
la l'heure actuelle 27 août dernier
avait suscité la polémique et même
l'indignation du président de la
république
le parquet de paris a ouvert une enquête
préliminaire en début de semaine pour
injure actes à caractère raciste pour
les responsables de l'hebdomadaire il
s'agissait au contraire dans cette
fiction de dénoncer la responsabilité
des africains dans l'horreur de l'
esclavage
on va retrouver tout de suite place du
trocadéro à paris notre reporter les la
fin à mouzon bonsoir lit la femme vous
avez suivi et vous êtes toujours place
du trocadéro pour cette manifestation de
soutien à danièle obono la députée qui
s'est exprimé il y à quelques minutes
maintenant
oui effectivement magal et ce
rassemblement vient tout juste de se
terminer un rassemblement
on a vu à peu près une centaine de
personnes parmi lesquelles aussi bien
des responsables politiques de la france
insoumise ou encore du npa
des représentants de syndicats ou encore
des citoyens pour qu'il était important
de venir ici apporter leur soutien à
danièle obono et puis nous avons parlé
avec l'organisatrice de ce rassemblement
mais aussi l'avocat
raquel garrido l'avocate de danièle
obono pour qui finalement cette fiction
de valeur actuelle est une attaque
contre la république
je propose de les écouter quand on lit
le texte de valeurs actuelles
on sent bien qu'il ya une volonté de
ramener daniel à un espèce de lointains
imaginaire qui serait ailleurs qu'en
france
et comme elle a la peau noire d'assez
forcément l'afrique c'est à dire c'est
si vous avez la peau noire ou séchés
vous ah bah non ça peut pas de la france
chez vous c'est c'est l'afrique
et si vous avez la peau noire qu'elle
peut être votre statut de l' esclavage
les savage et donc c'est cette réduction
un statut d'esclave à une à une
extranéité qui est présumé à travers les
générations à travers le temps c'est
quelque chose qui est qui a été qui a
été voulue contre danièle obono mais il
faut pas être naïf silva l'heure
actuelle s'attaque à cette figure
magnifique qu'est danièle obono députée
française extrêmement engagé extrêmement
présente à l'assemblée c'est parce
qu'elle est une porte parole de la
contestation
et c'est parce qu'elle est un soumise à
partir du moment où les africains et les
afrodescendants en ce moment relève la
tête et prennent la parole au nom de
leur dignité au nom de ce qu'il
représente dans ce pays
ils sont les extrêmes droites d'ailleurs
on pourrait dire que même certaines
parties de la gauche aussi son sont
soucieux de voir cette nouvelle parole
surtout qui dénonce le colonialisme le
racisme structurel et donc la suprématie
blanche je pense que c'est tout ça qui
est en jeu danièle obono qui arrivait
ici aux alentours de 19 heures alors que
le rassemblement avait commencé donc à
17 heures et elle a pris la parole elle
a remercié toutes les marques de soutien
qu'elle reçoit depuis une semaine
maintenant danièle obono qui estime
malgré les excuses un de geoffroy le
jeune le directeur de la rédaction de
valeurs actuelles
elle estime que ces excuses ne sont pas
recevables car cela te fait depuis
plusieurs années qu'elle est attaquée
elle estime qu'il faut dénoncer dénoncer
cette dernière publication qui est
finalement une attaque contre les
minorités visibles en france
ecoutez-la celle attaques contre la
députée que je suis presque pour ces
gens c'est insupportable qu'une femme
noire puisse être député de la
république pour eux nous sommes des
corps étrangers littéralement qu'il faut
faire émigrer envoyés en afrique et donc
c'est aussi pour ça que je tenais plat
avec mon écharpe pour réaffirmer le fait
que j'ai été élu et que je suis député
de la nation française et et que j'en
suis fier et que c'est parce que je suis
un des buts et que je suis aussi
insoumise et je suis insoumise parce que
je suis député et que c'est
c'est cette résistance et ses stars
soumission que je voulais réaffirmé en
étant ici est donc la meilleure réponse
est d'être présent de s'engager et de
militer de résister de dire non et de
pas se taire parce qu'en réalité ce qui
leur pose un problème c'est qu'on prenne
la parole en fait parce que tant qu' on
ne disait rien tant qu'on subit tant
qu'on est essentielle à faire marcher
l'économie et que on en demande pas trop
on n'est tolérée mais à partir du moment
où on ouvre
on our la voir et on dit non c'est ça
qui est intolérable pour eux alors
danièle obono donc a décidé de porter
plainte mais qui estime qu'au delà de la
bataille juridique il ya aussi une
bataille politique qui doit être mené
pour dénoncer ce qu'elle appelle un
racisme systémique en france
si beaucoup lit la femme pour toutes ces
précisions lit la femme ouzou en direct
de la place du trocadéro à paris
autre manifestation aujourd'hui dans la
capitale est celle des gilet jaune
contre les médias
le cortège a fait la tournée des sièges
dans la capitale voyaient ils ont ciblé
des chaînes du service public français
le groupe altis ou bien france médias
monde
ils réclament davantage de visibilité
dans les médias il dénonce le traitement
de l'information de ces grands groupes
et on a appris également hier qu'une
vingtaine de gilet jaune seront
prochainement jugés pour des
dégradations commises à surac de
triomphe en 2018 la justice qui
reconnaît néanmoins à demi-mot que ce ne
sont pas forcément les responsables
directs de ces saccages qui vont
comparaître
rania berrada
dix-sept personnes vont être jugées pour
le saccage de l'arc de triomphe à paris
le 1er décembre 2018 lors d'une
manifestation des gilet jaune
certains d'entre eux comparaîtront pour
vols et dégradations lors de l'acte iii
des gilet jaune du mobilier avait été
détruit et des oeuvres d'art dégradé le
préjudice avait été évalué à plus d'un
million d'euros
et les images avaient fait le tour du
monde cette journée de violence avait
donné lieu à 402 l'interpellation et au
placement en garde à vue de 378
personnes
le lendemain le chef de l'état emmanuel
macron c'était symboliquement rendu au
pied du monument où repose le soldat
inconnu
les 17 personnes mises en cause étaient
âgés pour la plupart d'une vingtaine ou
d'une trentaine d'années au moment des
faits la moitié avait un casier
judiciaire vierge
autre manifestation aujourd'hui celle
pour soutenir julian assange le procès
du fondateur de wikileaks doit reprendre
après demain à londres des manifestants
qui ont même rejoint le cortège des
gilet jaune aujourd'hui
depuis des mois il dénonce également le
silence des médias sur la détention du
lanceur d'alert nadège abderrazak c'est
la mobilisation de la dernière chance
pour les soutiens de julian assange
à deux jours de la reprise du procès
pour extradition du fondateur de
wikileaks plusieurs dizaines de
personnes se sont rassemblées
aujourd'hui ici à place de l'opéra pour
apporter leur soutien à julian assange
objectif interpeller l'opinion publique
emmanuel macron sur le sort du
journaliste australien amp d'après c'est
un manifestant la seule et
unique solution pour julian assange est
d'obtenir l'asile politique et aucune
charge contre lui il est accusé de
d'espionnage aux états unis parce qu'il
a froissé quelques ego en parlant des
crimes de guerre en irak en afghanistan
et à guantanamo et on s'acharne sur lui
d'une manière absolument honteuse et
c'est pour soutenir qui le fait qu'il
soit pas extradé aux états unis pour
cent soixante quinze ans de prison que
je suis là via cette contestation de de
toutes les oligarchies qui finalement
est en particulier les états unis qui
mènent à qui mène la danse 2 d'essayer
d'éliminer quelqu'un qui fait tout
simplement son boulot de journaliste et
qui est pour des on lui fait un procès
fallacieux pour parce qu'en fait c'est
un grain de sable dans la machine de big
brother et malheureusement il ya trop
peu de gens qui sont concernés parce que
sa liberté à lui c'est notre liberté à
nous et ça les gens ne comprennent pas
c'est très importante on l'appelle
julian assange est actuellement
incarcéré à la prison de haute sécurité
de belmarsh à londres et en cas
d'extradition il encourt une peine de
100 75 ans aux états unis pour avoir
divulgué des documents classés secret
défense sur les agissements de l'armée
américaine en irak et en afghanistan
notamment la justice britannique va
t'elle oui ou non extradé le journaliste
et lanceurs d'alertés australien et
c'est tout l'enjeu de ce procès
historique pour la liberté de la presse
qui s'ouvre ce lundi à londres plusieurs
reprises les soutien juridique de julian
assange ont demandé à la france de lui
accorder l'asile politique vous voyez ce
qu'en dit françois korber délégué
général de l'association robin des lois
il en appelle d'ailleurs au nouveau
garde des sceaux eric dupond moretti qui
a était l'avocat du lanceur d'alert
l'avocat dupond moretti le 1 février
devant toute la presse internationale a
dit demain incessamment souto dans
l'eure je demande au président de la
république le
l'adil politique pas très bien on a
applaudi parce qu on était sur un plan
de combat juridique si le demandez lui
mais c'était parfait et unis s'y
rattachent et voilà c'était des mois se
sont écoulés
l'avocat est devenu ministre le ministre
a peut-être des raisons d'état ou de
données en demander rendez-vous pour
l'instant on n'a pas de réponse mais on
s'attend pas en avoir
et personne ne permit pas trash qui a
accès au président de songer à lui dire
donc cette vidéo à sa bouche et je me
dis qu apparemment le ministre a oublié
les déclarations de l'avocat ce qui
effraie corps m'a longtemps en france
c'est triste mais qui ne nous empêche
pas de rester confiant pour faire
libérer afin d'une façon ou d'une autre
lancement des concertations nationales
pour la transition au mali aujourd'hui
des discussions entre les militaires au
pouvoir les partis politiques et la
société civile qui vise à ramener
justement ces civils à la tête du pays
une étape importante alors que le pays
est toujours en proie aux attaques
terroriste des islamistes grâce d'aia
éclaire nico une semaine pour sceller
l'avenir politique du mali initialement
prévu sur deux jours est annulé une
première fois la tante attendue réunion
sur la transition du pouvoir malien a
débuté aujourd'hui dans la capitale
bamako des négociations en deux temps un
premier pour s'entendre sur des
objectifs communs en présence des partis
politiques de la société civile des
groupes armés signataires de l'accord de
paix de 2015 et des syndicats puis un
second pour trouver un terrain d'entente
permettant une transition politique
idéal cette fois en présence des
délégués nationaux régionaux et des
membres de la diaspora
en tout une semaine de débats avec la
volonté d'inclure toutes les parties
prenantes mais le sujet de la crispation
majeur semble être celui de la durée de
la transition politique
pour le rmp l'ex majorité du président
déchu bk pas de position officielle même
si soumeylou boubèye maïga ex premier
ministre dit bk table sur un an voire un
an et demi sous la houlette d'un
président et d'un premier ministre civil
pour moussa mara lui aussi ex premier
ministre l'ancienne classe politique
devra avant tout se mettre en retrait au
profit des civils
il faut que la société civile soit mise
en avant pour que de nouveaux acteurs
émergent
de son côté le parti initiateur de la
consultation populaire le m5 rfp estime
qu'un an et demi à deux ans avec un
président civil serait souhaitable
les deux acteurs majeurs de la
transition pour le changement attendu
par le peuple malien vous la mise sur
pied d'un nouveau mali sans le m5 rfp et
le cnsp sont en train de travailler pour
regrouper l'ensemble des forces vives de
la nation ou définir ensemble tout ce
qui concerne la transition
le format la durée et les autres
caractéristiques de la tradition tous
les acteurs qui participent au débat ont
la même préoccupation s'assurer qu'il
s'agira bien d'une transition et non
d'une confiscation du pouvoir par la
junte
l'imam dicko figures majeures de la
contestation avait mis en garde les
militaires sur ce point je serai enfin
les eaux
s'ils ont achevé la révolution mais je
les reverrai
de tenu parole alors après ces
concertations d'autres points resteront
à éclaircir
et alors que la junte se targue d'un
coup d'état sans heurts son putsch s'est
soldé par quatre morts et 15 blessés
reste le cas de 20 personnes arrêtées le
jour du coup d'état est toujours détenu
à bamako une enquête à leur sujet a été
ouverte par la minus m'a envoyé à
présent l'analyse de thiant belle bimba
ira il est journaliste et directeur de
la publication de la voix du mali
je crois que la démarche est un peu plus
acceptable en associant tout le monde et
que cette démarche soit une démarche
participative et que tout le peuple
malien se retrouvent y compris les la
majorité d'hyères et les contestataires
de la route-de-lorient
sauf que de ce côté des contestataires
il faut arrêter maintenant de contester
vous êtes mise à l'épreuve il faut se
mettre à la table proposer des solutions
concrètes et ne pas se battre pour
monopoliser ou prendre en otage encore
et on pouvoir transitoire qui
n'appartiennent ni aux militaires ni aux
contestataires et appartient à tout le
peuple malien même aux anciens soutiens
et ami du président sortant ibrahim
boubacar kéita
en tout cas l'objectif et ses
concertations d'avoir cette descente en
sus de quoi occuper les 10 11 et 12 est
sorti avec une tuque leurs 6 par rapport
à à la présence de la transition ou au
moins à une liste est cher ou de
laquelle on va tirer un président de la
transition
un premier de la transition est composé
un gouvernement limité avec des
technocrates et envahit maintenant par
rapport à la charte de la transition aux
missions assignées à la transition les
partis politiques les syndicats les
associations dans une constituante
je pense que c'est cela qui s'épaissit
la crise sanitaire en amérique latine à
présent avec 7 millions 600 mille cas à
ce jour et plus de 280 mille morts
certains pays commencent à desserrer les
mesures de restriction c'est le cas
notamment au chili qui a franchi cette
semaine le seuil des 400 mille cas
confirmés une épidémie qui se stabilise
après avoir connu un pic en juin et en
juillet un relâchement des restrictions
sanitaires salutaire pour l'économie du
pays
françois disque évite un des compliments
à deux vitesses c'est ce qu'a choisi le
gouvernement chilien un plan cinq étapes
baptisé pas à pas est appliqué à des
rythmes différents selon les régions les
quartiers à santiago depuis cette
semaine les terrasses de plusieurs
quartiers chics de la capitale peuvent
enfin rouvrir une bonne nouvelle pour ce
restaurateur fermé depuis plusieurs mois
nous avions peur de rouvrir parce que
nous n'avions pas d'espacés extérieurs
nous pensions que nous ne pourrions pas
gagner d'argent que c'était plus
rentable de rester fermés mais la
municipalité a pris une excellente
initiative et nous a permis d'utiliser
une partie des trottoirs pour augmenter
le nombre de tables changement de décor
dans ce quartier encore strictement
confiné de l'est de l'agglomération de
santiago
ici à l'eau hermida la crise sanitaire a
aussi réveillé un drame que le chili
croyait avoir éradiqué la fin pour
tenter d'y remédier les soupes
populaires se sont multipliés comme
celle des guerras les guerrières créé
par neuf femmes chaque jour est libre
175 repas des habitants frappée par la
fin c'est ce qui nous pousse nous et pas
seulement moi être ici tous les jours à
leur donner de la nourriture un repas
correct a essayé de faire de notre mieux
à leur donner de quoi se nourrir et pas
seulement de l'eau potable jeu
sais pas si on pourra leur donner
quelque chose demain alors si on peut le
faire maintenant ont donné leur de la
nourriture digne de ce nom quelque chose
de chaud cela fait cinq mois que je n'ai
rien reçu et je n'ai eu que ce qu'il me
donne rien d'autre parce qu'il veut
fournissent de la nourriture chaque jour
chaque jour du pain chaque jour dégoûté
pour nos enfants
selon les associations caritatives au
manque à 200 soupe populaire fonctionne
dans tous santiago où vivent plus de 7
millions de personnes
ces derniers jours le gouvernement a
levé l'interdiction de voyager à
l'intérieur du pays en raison de la
stabilisation du taux d'occupation des
hôpitaux et des décès du recours aux
navires us
le couvre-feu national entre 22h et 5h
du matin est lui toujours en vigueur
et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
avec pascal drouhaud président de
l'association lacq front et spécialiste
de l'amérique latine
bonsoir pascal droz
merci d'être avec nous sur rt france on
le voit l'amérique latine commencent à
sortir de ce calvaire de cette crise
sanitaire c'est un des continents qui a
été le plus touché par le virus après
l'europe
il voit le bout du tunnel je ne crois
pas que il voit le bout du tunnel mais
en effet la pandémie a des conséquences
à long terme
l'amérique latine on le voit dans votre
reportage est entré en fait dans cette
phase de confinement de mesures de
prévention de l'expansion du virus d en
fait le mois de mars dernier
dès le mois de mars et avril et c'est
bien pourquoi aujourd'hui la crise
sociale est aussi grave parce que six
mois après l'amérique latine connaît des
pics de pandémie 7 millions 6,2 cas à ce
jour près de 280 mille décès et on voit
bien que les pays on l'a bien vu dans
votre reportage notamment des économies
aussi importante que le chili ne sont
pas pas justement sorti de la crise
sanitaire mais la crise économique et
sociale devient désormais tellement
inquiétante qu'il est
indispensable de commencer à des confiné
en fait les pays
ceci étant n'oublions pas que le
continent latino-américain ses 54 % de
l'économie informelle
54 % de population active qui
travaillent dans l'économie informelle
et qui ne bénéficie donc pas par
définition de toutes les aides sociales
que pourraient apporter les états mais
là aussi on est dans le coeur du
problème c est à eux ont des budgets
contraints parce que les recettes
fiscales ne sont pas extrêmement
importante et donc ces pays se sont
concentrés sur des aspects particuliers
notamment la le domaine régalien la
sécurité notamment les forces armées est
donc évidemment tout ce qui touche à
l'accompagnement et le social à la
protection sociale a été le point faible
en général durant ces dernières années
et le la pandémie révèle ses faiblesses
et révèle donc aujourd'hui ce qui se
révèle aujourd'hui à travers une crise
sociale économique importante mais
également politique
on le voit à l'écran évidemment cette
situation de tension sociale et de
manque de protection sociale
s'accompagne inévitablement de tensions
politiques la raison de ces tensions
dites moi si je me trompe va vous
parliez d'un confinement extrêmement
long ça a été le cas notamment pour le
chili mais pas pour le pas pour le
brésil par exemple au chili a dû imposer
des mesures drastiques t drastique et d
des répressions assez importants pour
maintenir les gens à domicile
contrairement au brésil donc est ce
qu'il n'ya pas des géométries variables
néanmoins alors oui d'abord un
l'amérique latine elle est diverse
l'amérique latine les caraïbes ce sont
33 pays de 33 pays 33 réalité différente
ça ne faut surtout pas considérer
l'amérique latine comme même bloc
ce serait une erreur primo secundo vous
le savez le brésil est un état est un
pays fédéral donc les confinements ont
eu lieu au brésil
ils les mesures ont été prises par les
états je pense notamment à sao paulo
avec des tensions sociales avec l'état
fédéral avec le pool le coup brasilia et
le président fédéral brésilien mais il
ya eu des mesures fortes qui ont été
prises notamment à sao notamment à rio
et dans d'autres états du brésil qui lui
aussi est d'où là aussi des tensions et
d'un débat politique extrêmement vif et
vous avez raison de le rappeler ces
dernières semaines pour ne pas venir ces
derniers mois entre l'état fédéral et
les états qui composent le pays du
brésil mais en fait tous les pays latino
américains on était en fait les bons
élèves au tout début de la pandémie en
mars/avril locaux vides n'était pas
arrivé en amérique latine mais ils ont
appliqué par mesure de prévention des
mesures donc d'aider des mesures très
strictes mais qui sur la durée
évidemment ont des effets absolument
dramatique
je rappelle que c'est aujourd'hui près
de 37% de la population latino
américaine nous parlons de plus de 230
millions de personnes qui vivent dans la
pauvreté ou dans l'extrême pauvreté
aujourd'hui qu'elles sont près de 40
millions de personnes pendant qu'ils qui
sont entrées dans la pauvreté depuis le
début de duke au vide alors l'europe et
soutenu on l'a vu financièrement qu'en
est il de ces pays
quelles pourraient être les conséquences
politiques et économiques
alors vous parlez de l'europe donc en
effet la crise révèle
la faiblesse de la solidarité régionale
il n'y a pas de plan de relance
régionaux en amérique latine alors même
que les structures régionales existent
l'alliance du pacifique notamment qui
rassemble le mexique le chili la
colombie le pérou des économies qui
faisait partie des plus importantes du
continent
par exemple nous pouvons parler aussi du
mercosur du sica en amérique centrale et
pour autant où sont ces structures
aujourd'hui et notamment à travers la
mise en place de plans de relance elles
ne sont nulle part donc c'est ça la
carence en fait et le point de faiblesse
en amérique latine
c'est un continent qui était émergents
mais sept mois après le début de la
pandémie l'émergence paraît bien
lointaine
et on sent bien que le continent est en
train de sombrer dans des tensions qui
leur en bois aux décennies extrêmement
difficile des années 70 80
donc oui les plans des plans de relance
pourrait être nationaux mais en effet on
voit bien qu'aujourd'hui l'absence
régional et est très forte
merci beaucoup pascal drouhaud d'avoir
répondu à nos questions ce soir sur rtl
france des mesures sanitaires contesté
en europe après l'allemagne la semaine
dernière les italiens manifestent à
vendre aujourd'hui pour protester contre
les mesures prises dans le cadre de la
lutte contre la virus comme le port du
masque la distance sociale des règles
qu'ils aient celui là une sorte de
dictature salutaire l'italie et pourtant
ceux des rues le pays qui a payé le plus
lourd tribut en europe avec plus de 35
mille morts
voyez ce conte di matteo ghisalberti
rédacteur en chef de kutch médias il ya
beaucoup de contradictions dans la façon
où il a été appliqué cette mesure qui
était très respectée par les italiens il
faut dire surtout dans les régions où il
ya eu plus de morts malheureusement
c'est le cap avec simple de lombardie et
mais un peu comme en france il ya des
contradictions parce que par exemple au
début de la pandémie quand par exemple
le président de la région lombardie à
thio fontana avait été filmée lors d'un
duplex avec le mas et on l'avait traité
des chacals on lui avait dit que en fait
on avait accusé de faire vouloir faire
de la politique sur un exploitant de
virus la peur est maintenant finalement
on a un peu l'impression que c'est le
gouvernement qui fait le discours a le
même discours ou à maintenir la peur
c'est ça l'accusation ainsi parlé et
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
votre fidélité
on se retrouve dans 30 minutes rester
avec nous
[Musique]
chacun pour soi dieu pour tous petit
coup politique n'a jamais été obligé de
dire la vérité mais idée courageuse des
mots qui comptent à l on soit vient de
l'ignorance
aujourd'hui on a une gauche l'extrême
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
nous allons évoquer ici des sujets
stratégiques pour notre pays et sur ces
dossiers sensibles